gesture let me start with you for a
moment what was it like to have your
whole genome sequenced I honestly not
that exciting d it was frustrating first
of all it took a long time for them to
get around to doing it they took some
blood then I waited a long long time and
then they told me gee you know there's
not anything really exciting and as dr.
Auster said I could have told them that
without not only without 400 which is
now the retail price of 23andme but or
not a thousand or not even several
hundred thousand the the fact is those
of us who are interested in doing this
for ourselves we're not interested many
of us in finding out about ourselves but
in offering dated back into the pool so
that in the future other people can find
out about themselves I'm 50 today I'm 58
and I'm not dead yet so it's pretty
clear there's nothing drastically wrong
with me I may get Alzheimer's I probably
won't get Parkinson's it's not in the
family neither as Alzheimer's so as you
said knowing the family history is is
often it's pretty indicative but in the
future the data that 23andme is
collecting and in the meantime it shows
to its customers because I believe
that's their right is going to be very
very useful over time will collect more
data will collect a lot of phenotype as
well as genotype data and our pitch to
our consumers is we try very carefully
not to present it as a medical service
and it's not with a wink it's because it
really isn't it's because it's
interesting it's fascinating you can
call it in our citizen some people are
interested in their ancestry some people
are adopted or for whatever reason don't
know who their parents are and for them
I think it's a lot more fascinating than
for most of us but the real the real
goal here is that
the scenario you described at the end
the 61 year old man to help make that
happen because it's going to require
hundreds of thousands of genomes and the
phenotypes to give us that kind of
information and we think getting
consumers excited about it is the best
way to do that have you found stuff
about your own ancestry of and
understand you've had relatives do this
well I've had 30 relatives do it and
third it's it's fascinating but medical
useful no I there's a chance it could be
but honestly knowing that you're I think
the advantage of knowing you have a
quote twenty-four percent risk of
something which i agree with you is a
spurious number it's not necessarily
that the advice is going to be any
better but that looking at that number
makes you take it more seriously there's
it's psychological but every doctor
knows how important psychology is
compliance is probably one of the
medicines worse problems it's getting
people to do what they know they should
do already and if looking at your genome
and understanding your risk of type 1
diabetes is something like seventy to
eighty percent heritable and your risk
of type 2 diabetes is only twenty five
percent heritable which means the rest
of it the rest of your risk of type 2
diabetes is what you do that kind of
quantification not the precision that
the quantification I believe can help to
modify people's behavior